just a few months ago the general
international audience had no clue who
vladimir zelinski was but ever since
russia invaded ukraine zielinski has
transformed into a national hero who's
willing to stand with his people till
the very last second
now wars aren't won by any singular
person everyone from the military and
the civilians to the donators and the
press play significant roles in securing
a victory but with that being said none
of these parties would be able to
contribute to their maximum ability
without great morale and there's no
doubt that zilenski has done a great job
in maintaining high spirits considering
this strong performance you would think
that zelinski has a lot of experience
leading teams and people but this isn't
actually true
in fact zielinski started off as an
entertainer and he leverages popularity
to get into office while many ukrainians
likely had their doubts when a former
comedian was elected into office
zelinski has more than proved that he's
capable of the role so here's the story
of volody merzelenski and how he became
the savior of ukraine
taking a look back zelinski was born on
january 25th 1978 in the former
ukrainian soviet socialist republic in
terms of heritage zielinski's family was
jewish and they were severely impacted
by the holocaust many of them were
victims of the holocaust and had lost
their lives to it meanwhile zielinski's
grandfather was a part of the soviet
army and fought against germany given
this painful past much of zielinski's
family and their jewish friends decided
to leave the soviet union and start
fresh lives in israel and the united
states but zielinski's parents decided
to stay zielinski's mother was an
engineer while his father was a math
professor so clearly this choice wasn't
based on queer limitations as they would
have had plenty of opportunities abroad
as well
anyway though zelinski was born in
modern-day ukraine he spent the first
few years of his life in the mongolian
city of urdunet which is where his
father worked at the time it wasn't
until elementary school that zelinski
moved back to ukraine in terms of his
school life his peers say that the main
characteristics they recall about
zielinski are that he got good grades
and wore an earring moving into high
school at age 17 zielinski would join
the local kbn team which competed in
comedy tournaments each team was
required to come up with a funny
greeting improvise some jokes and
compose a humorous song that they would
perform in front of the audience and the
judges zelinski excelled in this
competition and would even be invited to
join a legacy team that would go on to
win kvn's major league in 1997. after
this victory zielinski would form his
own comedy team called the kovartal 95
that would regularly perform at the
major leagues between 1998 and 2003. in
the meantime zelinskiya also kept up
with scola as well he passed the english
language test at age 16 and would
receive an educational grant to go study
in israel but zielinski's father
insisted that he stay in ukraine so
zielinski would go on to attend kiev
national economic university where he
earned his law degree given this
traditional education you would think
that zelinski picked up a corporate job
following college but this was not the
case the comedy competitions that he was
doing on the side had garnered him a
decent amount of popularity with the
ukraine television and zielinski decided
to leverage his popularity to enter the
show business
zielinski's first career within the tv
industry outside comedy was not acting
but actually producing starting in 2003
zielinski began producing tv shows for a
ukrainian tv channel called oneplus one
the show featured the comedy team that
he founded and given their previous
popularity with kbn it didn't take long
for them to build up a loyal audience
around the same time zilinski also
dabbled with some other tv genres
including ukraine's version of dancing
with the stars this time he wasn't a
behind the scenes producer or director
though he was actually one of the
competitors in 2006 and zielinski would
not only become a star performer on the
show but he would actually win the
entire show as you would guess this win
significantly rose to lindsay's
popularity as he became a national tv
star zelinski would use this newfound
popularity to branch out from comedy and
try his hand at traditional acting in
2008 he would star in his first feature
film called love in the big city
technically the movie was a romantic
comedy so zielinski didn't venture out
too far from his roots but this was his
first time starring in something much
longer than a simple skit or tv show the
movie had a rather modest budget of 3.5
million dollars but it pulled in 9.1
million dollars so it looks like it was
a pretty good investment for the studio
the studio would go on to fund the two
sequels to the movie called love in the
big city 2 and loving the big city 3. in
the first sequela zielinski remained a
key actor in the film but in the second
sequel he would transition into being a
producer aside from this franchise
zielinski also worked on the movies
office romance art time razepsky vs
napoleoni 8 first dates and its 2
sequels and paddington bear and its
sequel with major roles in all these
productions zielinski quickly became an
alias celebrity and he would start to
use this fame to fight against what he
thought were injustices one example of
this was in 2014 when the ukrainian
ministry of culture was attempting to
ban russian artists from ukraine
zelensky was a staunch proponent against
his legislation and voiced his concerns
nationally unfortunately ukraine would
go on to enact this ban in 2015 anyway
but zielinski did try while these calls
went unheard it wasn't long until
politicians could no longer ignore
zolensky as he would soon get the people
of ukraine on his side
politicians often spend decades building
up major political runs by starting
small and slowly working up the ladder
they might start as a representative and
then become a senator and then become a
governor and then finally they might run
for president
even donald trump who ran with no
political background had been teasing a
presidential bid as far back as 1988
but for zielinski his rise to power was
truly something that unfolded overnight
it all started in 2015 when zielinski
starred in a tv show called servant of
the people
in the show zielinski played a humble
school teacher that often ranted about
political corruption and various
shortfalls of the political system and
many clips from his rant started going
viral on social media soon enough a lot
of news outlets and the journalists are
speculating if zelinski would make a
political run and all this speculation
along with the success of the show
convinced lenski that he should give it
a shot in march of 2018 the people at
kovartal95 had launched a political
party called servant of the people
despite the creation of the party
zielinski didn't officially announce
that he was going to run for several
months he always gave ambiguous answers
similar to what trump is doing right now
with the 2024 election even though
zielinski didn't officially announce his
campaign a lot of polls included him
anyway and he generally performed
exceptionally well it was until new
year's eve of 2018 that zelinski would
officially announce his campaign on his
own show and once he announced his
campaign he shot up in the polls from
being a favorite to being a decisive
leader zielinski didn't campaign like
ordinary politicians though by giving
long interviews and speeches instead
zielinski went ahead and embraced what
people knew him for comedy he posted
dozens of humorous videos on youtube and
instagram that mocked the political
establishment in other words he cleverly
leveraged the power of social media to
run his campaign which would prove to be
extremely effective on march 31 2019 the
first round of the presidential election
was completed and zielinski would win 30
of the vote for perspective second place
only garnered 16 of the vote and just a
few weeks later on april 21st 2019 the
second round of the election would take
place and zulinski would win in a
landslide securing 73 of the vote so
zielinski hasn't even been president for
three years yet but he's already been
involved in two of the biggest political
controversies in ukraine history speak
about perfect timing
with how significant the russian
ukrainian conflict has become most of us
have completely forgotten about the
trump ukrainian drama that unfolded a
few years ago but this was quite a big
deal too as it led to the second
impeachment of donald trump the story
goes that shortly after zielinski was
elected trump called him and asked him
to investigate bain's business dealings
within ukraine which seemed reasonable
given that there seemed to be some
evidence of potential corruption the
problem though was that trump used
military aid as a bargaining chip and
refused to release 391 million dollars
worth of aid until zilinski publicly
announced a probe into buying dealings
in ukraine the military aid was supposed
to be used to strengthen ukraine's
eastern border and today it has become
painfully evident why this was so
important trump ended up releasing the
aid after his phone call with zilinski
became public but it ended up costing
him a second impeachment just as this
fiasco came to an end zelensky was hit
with another massive hurdle which was of
course the pandemic handling kovat 19
has been one of the biggest challenges
for politicians around the world from
enacting lockdowns and mass mandates to
distributing vaccines and returning to
normal life every step has been heavily
scrutinized by the media and it doesn't
help that people are heavily divided on
these subjects these issues were no
different within ukraine and
unfortunately they've experienced four
major surges since the start of the
pandemic you could say that zelinski
stood with these people during the
pandemic as well given that he caught
the illness early on before the vaccine
was approved nevertheless like the rest
of the world ukraine was just to lighten
restrictions and returned normal life as
they moved into 2022 and then the
russian invasion speculation started to
go through the roof for some reason it
looks like the lenski just can't catch a
break
by now i'm sure all of you guys know
what's going on in ukraine after weeks
of increasing pressure on ukraine by
deploying soldiers all around the
country putin decided to invade in the
last week of february at the time of
making this video no country has really
committed to helping ukraine enter the
military aid however countries and
companies from around the world have
been working together to financially and
economically punish russia this includes
loads of sanctions bans on russian
aircraft companies refusing to do
business with russia and tons of
pushback from the public while all of
these are valiant efforts in helping
ukraine in the end it's the ukrainian
people that are physically defending the
country and at the helm we have
zielinski right now it's unclear how
much longer the conflict will last and
what the result will be
there have been a few meetings between
representatives from both countries but
we are yet to receive a concrete
resolution looking forward if zilensky
and ukraine survive the conflict there's
no doubt that zielinski will be seen as
a wartime hero and he won't be leaving
the presidential position any time soon
even if things turn sour and zielinski
is captured or worse he definitely
didn't go down without a fight and i'm
sure he'd be remembered for decades to
come
for everyone's sake though hopefully we
stick with scenario number one but
that's just what i think do you guys
support zielinski and ukraine comment
that down below
also drop a like if you think zielinski
is doing a better job than lifelong
politicians and of course consider
checking out our international channels
to watch your videos in other languages
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you